d'arbres qui pousse dans la région de
chiapas au sud du mexique et dont on
tire cette poudre va sans doute
révolutionner le traitement des grands
brûlés en tout cas c'est à paris que
prend l'industrie pharmaceutiques upsa
son pdg vient de signer un protocole
d'exclusivité avec le mexique l'enjeu
est selon lui capitale c'est une
thérapeutique absolument extraordinaire
des brûlures du secondaire c'est un
produit qui a un pouvoir analgésique
important d'actes est ici deux
antibiotiques surtout cicatrices upsa
implantée à jeun et dans la région
parisienne est une affaire privée
presque familiale avec un peu plus de
1000 employés elle se situe à la 22e
place des industries pharmaceutique
française
son produit leader est très connu
l'aspirine effervescente présente dans
84 pays elle exporte 25% de sa
fabrication
elle a d'ailleurs obtenu l'oscar de
l'exportation il ya cinq ans voilà qui
situe bien la combativité de cette
entreprise qui n'hésite pas à prendre
des risques dans cette affaire sont des
obstacles en amont pour la fourniture du
produit
j'espère que ça ira bien nous avons
maintenant les obstacles normaux de tous
produits pharmaceutiques et probablement
une invitée d'un avis très difficile à
pratiquer une toxicologie sans doute
facile et après les choisir ont beaucoup
l'enjeu est considérable sur le plan
éthique sur le plan sur la chirurgie sur
le plan de cicatrisation mais autrement
dit c'est aussi un très joli coup pour
un laboratoire pharmaceutique français
je l'espère j'espère tout ça c'est lié
mais on est quand même impressionné
d'abord par le côté éthique de l'afp
quand on a vu des grands brûlés traité
comme nous les avons vus on est vraiment
obligé d'essayer de le faire est-ce que
la cicatrisation des grands brûlés tient
dans cette poudre si tout va bien un
médicament français devrait être sur le
marché dans trois ans